And then the question is what
rushes in to fill a vacuum?
Well,
if you look at the case
of the Soviet Union,
it seems quite instructive,
doesn't it?
I mean,
there's a 30 year period where there's
tremendous intellectual class say between
a materialist and empirical perspective
and an Russian Orthodox perspective.
The Russian Orthodox perspective loses
its attractiveness for the reigning
intellectual elite and the
preset positions of communism,
which appear rational by contrast,
which by all evidence we're
not rush in to fill the gap.
And I want to read you
something that nature wrote.
It's perhaps the most
famous thing he ever said,
although it's almost entirely taken
out of context and misquoted and if not
misquoted,
at least misunderstood.
Because nature was one of these strange
people who was capable of living 50 or
even 100 years into the future.
And although he was,
is generally regarded as an enemy of
Christianity and superstition and was
certainly an unbelievably outspoken
opponent of Christian traditionalism.
He also knew that if you
let the old gods die,
the probability that blood would flood
the land was virtually 100% so let me
read you what he wrote.
Have you not heard of that mad man who
lit a lantern in the bright morning
hours,
ran to the market place
and cried incessantly?
I seek God as many of those who do not
believe in God were standing around just
then.
He provoked must much laughter.
Why did he get lost?
Said one.
Did he lose his way like a child
said another or is he hiding?
Is he afraid of us because he
gone on a voyage or emigrated?
That's the yelled and laughed.
The Madman jumped into their midst
and pierced them with his glances.
Where there is God,
he cried.
I shall tell you,
we have killed him.
You and I,
all of us are as murderers,
but how have we done this?
How were we able to drink up the sea?
Who gave us the sponge to
wipe away the entire horizon.
What did we do when we unchained
this earth from its sun?
Whether is it moving now,
whether are we moving
now weigh from all sons?
Are we not plunging
continuously backwards,
sideward forward in all directions?
Is there any up or down left?
Are we not straying as though
through an infinite nothing?
Do we not feel the breath of empty space?
Has it not become colder is not night
and more night coming on all the while?
Must not lanterns be lit in the morning.
Do we not hear anything yet of the noise
of the grave diggers who are burying
God?
Do we not smell anything
yet of God's decomposition?
God's to decompose.
God is dead.
God remains dead.
We have killed him.
How much shall we,
the murderer of all murderers,
comfort ourselves?
What was holiest and most powerful of
all that the world has yet owned has bled
to death under our knives.
Who will wipe this blood office?
What water is there for
us to clean ourselves?
What festivals of Atonement?
What Sacred Games shall we have to invent?
He's not the greatness of
this deed too great for us.
Must we not ourselves become
God simply to seem worthy of.
It
allows you can tell that's
a much different notion
from the casual God is dead
quotation that's most generally
associated with nature.
Well,
what is he saying?
What he's saying?
Something like this.
A system like Christianity
or any system that's con,
that's oriented as society for thousands
and thousands of years can't simply be
eradicated by a casual gesture,
without consequences in
suing and its aftermath.
What consequences will need you says,
well,
we all know longer know up from down.
What does he mean by that metaphorically?
Well App.
That's where you're headed,
right and down.
That's what you want to stay away
from and when you eradicate the most
fundamental presuppositions
of your system of values,
then there is no up and there is no
down and then where are you precisely?
Well,
it's not so easy.
It's not so easy to say having not
necessarily ever been in that position.
What is your life like
when you don't know?
Up from down?
Is it merely neutral?
Is to is they're merely no value left.
Or could it possibly be the case that if
up and down have both been eradicated,
that the place that you're left in is
something much more akin to a permanent
state of suffering because maybe it's
only the case that the constant capacity
to strive for up in being an up that you
believe in the constant striving for up
is actually what makes
your life bearable to you.
And if you lost the sense of up and down,
the place that you would end up would
be not so much neutral as terrible.
Now,
if you have any belief system at all,
you do this.
So let's say you're an
advocate of left wing politics.
You take a pro environmental
stance or an anti corporate stance.
This is a relatively common
thing to do among undergraduates.
What do you do when you
hold that belief system?
You view the world as it lays itself out
and you explain the manner in which it
manifests itself in terms of the
axioms of that belief system.
And you may know that you can do it right.
You can tell a credible story about why
the world is the way it is by adopting
say,
an anti corporate perspective because
there are all sorts of terrible things
about the world that are a
consequence say of corporate.
And you might also say that,
and Piaget would say this,
that it's a necessary developmental
stage to acquire allegiance to a given
belief system.
Why?
Well,
any APP is better than none.
That might be the first observation.
So even if your belief system
is relatively insufficient
and easily challenged
on an intellectual grounds and
perhaps not very complete anyways,
the fact that it does lay out a
moral structure for you and tell you,
good for me,
evil and right from wrong,
that's up.
That's a plus.
That's an advantage.
Now it's relative intellectual
weakness and it's incoherence.
Assuming it,
it is incoherent to some degree,
that's a flaw,
but that doesn't mean that the effort
to establish a system like that is
worthless.
It's worthwhile and neat.
Just said,
say with regards to
Christianity and Europe,
he said,
well,
the errors,
intellectual and moral of Institutional
Christianity are essentially beyond
count.
But there's one thing
you have to remember,
first of all,
in ordering of that sort is
necessary because the alternative,
which is always hidden from you in so
far as you're inside a moral system,
the alternative as far
worse chaos that's worse.